[Music]
when I gotta ask you I follow you on
snapchat this morning I saw you hit the
gym with Blake how did that go it was
good he killed him this morning one of
the photo right I need to see that it's
so funny because he's so tall that like
literally no sweat suits fit him so he
always has floods like and with the
white sox between and he's like i feel
like you'd be there five minutes to be
like having a heart attack
he really he killed it it's funny I
actually was I always know it's cuz of
him that I worked out this morning I
wasn't gonna work out so I would I
thought that he's my trainer I get hurt
every day my back hurts my knee hurts
everything yeah uh yeah she got in I
mean look at she like to be born with
her genetics I mean my gosh isn't I mean
my god it's not fair isn't it hard to
choose to go to the gym or cuddle though
I find that it's tricky choice top real
husband
really not with you but with my husband
I find that I mean obviously you know
well they obviously like it's not like
I'm a disease or something I mean quite
that bad but but pretty bad anyway
you